Sharon puts her feet up her bare feet up  on a seat in a movie theater and they're  dirty wait I don't even care if they're  dirty man I mean a dirty feet  but is that ever appropriate in a movie  theater for someone's bare feet to be  put on a 60s it sure was right I mean I  I don't I would it's a good question  I did think about it I was like does  this I don't want to convey that she's  rude or impolite because she's neither  of those things if you had the space if  you don't have neighbors close by yeah  I'm gonna say it's okay okay maybe not  shoes anyway it's not shoes just your  feet Larry David may have a problem but  they weren't dirty they were dirty feet  couple other important movie discussions  perennials